you so much of this energy and this kind
of boisterous in-your-face I'm the
greatest in the world it comes from your
work with tenacious d the greatest rock
band on the right we are the greatest
we're the best do you think do you think
it's at all possible that your balls to
the wall I'm the best and everything I
do is amazing stick may have influenced
our current president is that possible
yes in fact I feel like Donald Trump saw
a tenacious D concert because it's like
oh that's our whole thing is just like
we are the greatest band in the world no
one could touch us we are the best and
he just saw us and said I'm gonna use
that technique I'm the greatest
president I got all the greatest people
all the best this business and then he
used it and became president and now
when we go out and perform tune agency I
always have like a little twinge of
guilt because it's like this evil
warlock stole our magic but just took
out all the iron in the good work and
now he's destroying the universe
this is my fault this is you your fault
you did this now your fault
you rocked too hard you robbed too hard
I'm sorry I just want to see America I
just want to see the footage of Trump
out of Tenacious D concert in 1998 going
like yeah okay
like just seeing his head in the crowd
stranger things have happened
yeah
you